bonjour ne regagne pas de me remercier
de répondre à nos questions par
téléphone les violences se poursuivent
encore aujourd'hui après mercredi
sanglant d'hier jusqu'où est ce que ça
peut aller les heures peuvent-ils encore
aller crescendo
oui comme je les dis sur votre antenne
il ya quelques jours je crains que la
jaune de pouvoir ou plutôt le conseil a
souvent de transition ne soit dans une
logique jusqu'auboutiste
parce que tout ce qui est des négations
tout ce qui est récriminations de la
communauté internationale depuis que le
29 octobre dernier à l'air de tomber un
peu dans des oreilles de sourds vous
parlez de la communauté internationale
justement l'onu a estimé cet après midi
qu'il s'agissait de violences je cite
tout à fait honteuse au-delà des
déclarations
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre des
nations désunies
alors ça va être un peu difficile parce
que on est quand même dans un pré carré
à problèmes donc le soudan théâtre
d'opérations l'ethiopie à côté un
théâtre d'opération avec plus de 2
millions de déplacés aujourd'hui rendez
les teams de mire en ethiopie si le
temps se corse un peu trop dire à risque
d'embrasement et plus de déstabilisation
de toute cette région de l'est d'où la
prudence à mon avis des nations unies de
la communauté internationale entre
guillemets on peut observer
m ce qu'il faut dire c'est que le train
de mesure de tension à a été déjà mise
en place avec la suppression des 700
millions de dollars que washington a
loupé attribué jusque là qu'à khartoum
est une somme qui aujourd'hui ne plus
reverser au gouvernement et je crois que
c'est des mesures de rétorsion qui vise
une seule chose eh bai vise au retour
d'un pouvoir civil et c'est d'ailleurs
le sens de la présente de la
représentante américaine molly fille à
khartoum en ce moment justement en quoi
cette présence peut-elle faire évoluer
les choses
je crains que ça ne peuvent pas bouger
les choses pour que vous voyez il ya
quelques jours encore je vous parlais de
d'une fin de non recevoir
que de la junte du général burhan
servait au reste de la communauté
internationale bon je le disais en
tenant compte de beaucoup de paramètres
je ne crois pas que la présence de
la représentante américaine au soudan
aujourd'hui puisse infléchir la
situation et quoi qu'on va vers quelque
chose qui va se porter davantage parce
que la junte militaire au pouvoir est
dans une logique aujourd'hui de se faire
entendre et vent est de faire de faire
triompher sa loi on vient de parler à
communauté internationale avec l'onu
avec les états unis et l'europe la
russie la chine en quoi le soudan est il
si stratégique
mais le soudan est stratégique parce que
il ya l'enjeu de l'accès à la mer rouge
donc par port soudan ce que vous devez
savoir c'est que justement la neige
militaire aérienne accord avec la russie
notamment pour
l'établissement d'une base navale en
bail de 99 ans et l'établissement d'une
base navale russe donc au soudan de
donnant la primeur l'accès à la mer
rouge de ce que les américains voient
d'un très mauvais oeil par ailleurs
recevoir que le soudan c'est un pour
tous frontalier de sept pays l'egypte
l'ethiopie l'erythrée la libye le tchad
la république centrafricaine et le
soudan du sud ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que en termes stratégiques
notamment aujourd'hui après la corrida
porter été signées en 2010 notre sont
omar béchir interdisant désormais les
territoires sous d'années comme base de
repli des repaires des rebelles
tchadiens qui sont recoupées soutenu par
paris vous comprenez qu'il ya un
rayonnement un enjeu dans la place de
dollars
les médias d'état ont annoncé cet après
midi à un rétablissement je cite
graduelle des réseaux de communication
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cette information oui
en stratégie de guerre les mobilisations
des dites les manifestations du million
parce que les pro gouvernement civil
s'était fixé pour objectif de rassembler
un million de personnes dans les rues
qui s'avère complexe car khartoum sans
réalité trois villes en retour à paris
une tourbe le banc cartoon et donc
depuis samedi dernier par exemple il ya
sept ponts sur dix qui donne accès à la
ville qui ont été bloqués aussi de
nombreux barrages pour empêcher les
manifestants de se rassembler je crois
que le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui c'est la
pérennité de ces manifestations
puisque pour une certaine opinion
en soudanaise mais les américains sont
accusés d'attiser les braises ya l'open
society qui financerait donc en somme à
ces manifestations et d'eau et donc vous
voyez un peu aujourd'hui il ya une
véritable en deux camps qui s'opposent
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions morgan palmer je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste de l'afrique et
consultant en stratégie internationale